and I'll tell you all about it when I
see you again that number one hit could
win three Grammys on February 15 see you
again with Wiz Khalifa and Charlie puth
now that video has been watched more
than a billion times on YouTube that's
crazy I love it I've been watching it
myself it has completely transformed
Charlie's life this time last year
nobody knew his name well now he's
working with Meghan Trainor and Selena
Gomez and our sobytia' Lacey put Charlie
on the spot about the next big thing
okay well now you gave me a little bit
of a scoop here that I have to go with
music video with Selena what kind of
ideas are you throwing around there
obviously with Megan things got a little
steamy
so what kind of route are we gonna go
with Selena I love the the what you're
getting at I mean I I'm it's so I mean
the song we're gonna wait for the song
to come out first Charlie and Selena
have been teasing us on snapchat so
we'll find out more when Charlie kicks
off his North American tour in March but
for now he's looking to bring home his
first Grammy man Wiz are very excited
you know we got tagged as like the
world's most unlikely duo but it's cool
so is Wiz your date to the Grammys are
you bringing it in no it will not be my
date I think we're gonna both bring our
moms that's so sweet
I love a good mom date with Charlie it's
all about the music
and the formula works after building a
YouTube following from his dorm Charlie
moved to LA just over a year ago his new
home in Hollywood Hills looks over the
Capitol Records building how does your
family keep you grounded they let me
know that 15 years ago we couldn't even
afford tomato sauce so we had to use
ketchup on spaghetti and that money can
go away really quickly and I'll tell you
all about it when I see you